Well, I can think of at two reasons why my
computer science professor from college may be upset with the quality
of this code. The first is that I'm doing something
repetitive inside my code. Things like move forward, turn right, move
forward, turn right. I do that four times, but I
don't use any sort of a loop. Another reason is that
the name of my function is draw_square. Which I do.
But then I go ahead and draw a circle inside that
function also. That doesn't seem quite logical to me.
So, based on those two ideas, what changes would you
make to the code that we've written thus far
to make it more usable? I want you to make
those changes and then upload a screenshot of the
code to the discussion forum. Here's an extra credit assignment,
which is to create a third turtle, and this one
will draw a triangle. Once you are done with that,
I want you to upload a screenshot of the new output to the discussion
forum. Make sure you check this box
after you've submitted your responses to the forum.